you tube the final frontier these are
the voyages of the Hank and John ship
nerdfighteria their continuing mission
to explore strange new nerd cultures
seek out new videos and new
randomizations to go boldly we do not
split infinitives here we're no nerd has
gone before
yeah okay I just went to see Star Trek
and I wanted to share my opinions and
thoughts with all of you this video
comes in two parts part one non spoilery
stuff so everybody can watch this part
Star Trek as it was being called were
Star Trek 11 oh my god there have been
11 is a continuation of a marvelously
fantastic and long-lived franchise that
began with William Shatner and Leonard
Nimoy through the vision of the
fantastic Gene Roddenberry may he rest
in peace if you have never seen the
original Star Trek you can do so on
YouTube uh they're free so you can go
out to an episode of the original series
right now it's kind of hilariously bad
or if you're like me you've been mostly
exposed to the next generation I
actually just found this it's a VHS tape
that the Katherine taped off of
television which has several Star Trek
The Next Generation episodes on it as
well as a made-for-tv documentary of
Star Trek The Next Generation so yeah
there is a huge nerd streak that runs
through this whole household so
obviously I have a lot invested in the
Star Trek franchise it was one of my
primary forming influences like mom dad
jean-luc Picard I wrote a song about it
so walking into that theater I was one
extremely excited into kind of nervous
there have been putting a really bad
Star Trek movies and I didn't want this
one to suck so let me get this out of
the way immediately it didn't suck well
done to the writers cast crew director
producer it was an extremely enjoyable
journey with maybe a few plot details
that didn't have to be wedged right so
awkwardly into the movie but overall a
marvelous extension of the franchise
tons of fun good story great
relationships between the characters
noting that as a fairly dorky Star Trek
fan pissed me off at all all the
characters played themselves very well
Simon Pegg is brilliant as McCoy the
little Russian child prodigy was
hilarious or who got to graduate from
being a glorified secretary to being a
freakin xeno linguist bones was great I
loved bones and I loved the bones
friendship I think that was done very
very well and of course the whole
kirk/spock strong bond formed on
opposing views of the universe thing was
really really well done too and heroes
fans you don't have to worry that you're
gonna freak out every time Spock comes
on the screen and be like I moved right
past it immediately
Sylar was not in a movie for me but my
overall impressions were that it was
very fun very well done a little less
cerebral than I generally like Star Trek
to be but something that I honestly hope
is only just the beginning in this new
franchise now part two the spoilery bits
it'll be a very good idea to stop
watching this video right now if you
have to see the movie
generally time travel annoys me in
movies I think it's kind of cheating
this coming from a lover of the evil
baby orphanage but basically Spock
knocking a whole Neeta verse that goes
exactly to where James Kirk's father is
going to be doesn't really make a lot of
sense to me and then Kirk gets knocked
down onto the planet where Spock has
been marooned and they run into each
other despite the fact that it's an
entire planet and Kirk only runs that
like a mile away from that giant
scorpion thing that didn't really work
for me but I didn't very much like the
little romance with the green girl I
liked the who thing I thought that was
hot and I'm a little bit of pissed off
that they thought that they could
destroy all of Vulcan it kind of
destroys the whole universe for me but I
understand why they did it big stakes
makes the impending doom of the
much more interesting oh my god in the
drill the drill jump scene and the
random crewman who had the bombs and the
drill jump scene I was like yeah random
crewman he's gonna die I'm very
interested to know what the rest of
nerdfighteria thought of this Star Trek
movie please leave your opinions and
comments or go to nerdfighters calm and
leave a longer review there we will be
featuring some of those over the weekend
Jon live long and prosper